[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMRUTA JOSHI: My inspiration
has undoubtedly been my mother.
She encouraged me to think
independently, to be curious,
and to speak up for myself.
ANU STRIVASTAVA: When I
started computer science,
I was terrified of the
first classes I had to take.
But I eventually
became really close
with one of my
algorithms professors.
And she inspired me to try
exploring out, doing projects
on my own, and learning about
different fields in computer
science.
So when I go to speak at
conferences like the Google
Cloud Summit, I really want to
make sure everyone there feels
empowered and safe to ask
questions, take charge
of their own careers, and
bring their new perspectives
to the table.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
I work in security.
And so asking questions is
really, really critical.
People who work in security come
from a variety of backgrounds,
whether they come
from literature,
from computer science, from a
marginalized group, whatever
it happens to be.
And they say, you know,
how do we actually make
this work better for the user?
If you're not doing that,
you're potentially missing
out on a key part of your job.
GRACE MOLLISON: One
manager in particular
has always said to
me, look, I don't
mind if you got a
problem, but I'd
appreciate you actually having
thought that problem through
and look and question it.
Even if it's an area that's
not my area of expertise,
I do try and actually look
around it at that problem,
look around it to see
how I can deal with it.
KATHY LEE: I became
a working mom.
I work fearlessly day and night.
When I worked for a
gentleman named Paul,
there came an extraordinary
career opportunity.
He encouraged me to step
out of my comfort zone
and go for the bigger
career opportunities.
ANAIS HAYES: When I
first joined Google,
one of the very
first things I heard
is a great quote from
Larry Page, which
is about having a healthy
disregard for the impossible.
And with a healthy disregard
for the impossible,
people can do
anything, and I think
that's incredibly powerful.
[MUSIC PLAYING]